get ready my violin represents
everything that makes me happy in life
for more Yeti
DreamWorks abominable and The Invisible
City the creature Brigade is finally
paying off now that people know
creatures exist I've made some updates
to our app ring ring creature pink that
allows people to alert us to creature
sightings they've chosen to live here
with us
[Applause]
[Music]
OMG what we do can be pretty dangerous
run but I have my magic to protect us
Pang don't move
sorry
in all new season
awesome with new adventures I've always
wanted to go to space
and new creatures you're all here it's
just like the movies when we work
together there's nothing we can't do
I can't imagine doing this without you
DreamWorks abominable and The Invisible
City the only way to see it is to
believe it